chris again not not suggesting that
dwayne haskins
can even play in this league we don't
know what they can play or not
but i think if we're going to find out
anywhere it's with the pittsburgh
steelers
agreed i mean i think it's a very smart
signing by the pittsburgh steelers
you know i heard everything you guys
talked about in that conversation you
brought up a lot of good points
you know hey we don't know what he's
going to be yet yeah he's a first round
pick
first round picks yes sometimes they can
be bus sometimes they're superstars we
know that
they're picked because of elite traits
right that's the thing
you're a first round pick because
evaluators look at you and go
whoa he has one or two things that are
elite
and he could become a superstar now
whether that person works and does all
the right things
to accomplish and really take advantage
of his own skills
hey that's on the coaching staff the
player all those type of things
dwayne haskins to me right off the bat
has two elite traits right off the bat
one is his size size is a skill right
big quarterback big ben tom brady they
can make throws in the pocket that kyler
murray couldn't dream of or won't even
attempt
then the other thing is he does have a
big arm there's no doubt
it's a big time arm i mean he can flick
the ball all over the field with great
ease
but the big issue with him and why i
like this signing too
is i don't think he's going to be
expected to play this year
i expect us to see big ben back one one
more
year that's what i'm expecting and
this will give him a year to mature to
what you guys are saying
this is a young kid who didn't play a
lot of college football he only played
one year
and they were the most talented team and
they kept things very simple for him
when he was playing
so i think it is and i heard some of the
same things you guys heard from people i
really trust
you know just immature ways about how he
approached a job you know
last guy in the building first one to
leave just didn't know exactly what it
took to be a franchise quarterback yet
i think this kid's a good kid i think he
does love football
and you get around a guy like mike
tomlin and a bunch of other crazy alpha
loving football guys
that could get him changed and get him
going right in the right direction i
think it's smart for both sides here
both sides yeah or so that's the signing
for hashtags let's go from haskins
the low end to the top end uh what are
you doing right now if you're the
houston texans what are you doing
about deshawn watson are you saying okay
he wants to be traded uh hey it's it's
it's almost february
we got combine coming up drafts gonna
get free agency
let's just get as much as we can open
the doors and uh
and see what kind of offers come in is
that is that your approach
well i i think i mean i think it's gonna
go there no matter what to this point
right now
because i don't know where the
relationship goes with desean watson
until we
kind of see who's hired as the head
coach and where it goes from there
i do feel like they're trying to appeal
to him and now trying to make up for all
the dumb things they've done
you know over the last few weeks um i
don't know guys i don't know how you
feel
i'm just if you made me bet money my gut
whatever it is
i i would say he's out of houston
i i i expect him at some point to say i
don't want to be there anymore
but there's only there's one thing that
i think of that maybe could save it
if eric the enemy is hired as the head
coach then maybe i could see that
working out but man houston's not gonna
be like
they're gonna try to salvage this is
what i'm really saying they're gonna do
their best to try to make him happy and
make this happen because
you guys know i mean he's special
he's a superstar he is definitely one of
the five or six best quarterbacks in the
game
he can carry your team when your team
is crappy and that's that's special
there's not a lot of guys out there that
are like that um
so they're gonna hold and try to make it
work first but i think ultimately he
will be out of there and it's gonna be
some trade market for him
chris would you have known
or would you have guessed and i know
he's played only a few years compared to
drew brees
would you have guessed that desean
watson has the highest completion
percentage in nfl history
no i would not have guessed that 67
67.8 percent he is
breezes at 67.7 but i mean he is the
highest most accurate quarterback by
completion percentage
nfl history as as of this moment is
deshaun yeah well
i mean it it's i didn't it's shocking
because i didn't think of it that way
but not surprised we've had this but
we've had this discussion where as far
as
he's a real thrower a real pocket passer
he wants to surgically dissect you
in the pocket and then when all else
fails he wants to get the hell out of
town and then he'll make plays extending
them with his legs
and on the run and doing those things
and i'll just say this too as far as
like
the completion percentage thing too you
know
they they're not a dink and dunk often
so his completion percentage is high
while also throwing very high degree
level
of throws they're not looking for four
yard completions in houston he's usually
hitting
20 yard comebacks 10 yard outs you know
15 yard in cuts
50 yard post down the middle he's a
special special talent
you know he's right there on the cusp of
mahomes rogers and allen
but but in terms of um in terms of uh
what you said about the enemy michael
this just occurred to me because we've
been i was i was saying
you know some of the things that maybe
even if it happens in a roundabout back
door
not the ideal way they lie to him but
end up with the coach he wants
and and they hold firm maybe it works
out but here's my issue with that and it
just dawned on me chris
is that if you're the texans and you've
done everything wrong to this point
you can't throw you can't throw more bad
you can't throw more money at bad money
in other words like what i'm trying to
get at is you can't compound the mistake
by trying to appease him by hiring the
quarterback you think he wants
when by the way he's already done with
him like
this is a cal mcnair issue and by
extension of jack eastwood issue
i don't believe there's anything they
can really do to make him feel
differently about playing for that
organization
so the worst thing they could do is hire
a coach
who if they don't want to hire him
regardless is hire a coach that they
will think will give them a chance
to keep him and he's like no i when i
asked for the enemy you wouldn't give
them to me
i want to i want to be traded regardless
now you have a coach
that you weren't crazy about what they
have to do is hire they've already hired
a gm they wanted
hire the damn coach you wanted if this
happens to be the enemy great
if it ain't be consistent you know what
i'm saying mike
oh no i mean i'll go fine the hell with
you mike i'll talk but i i
i think hey i agree with you
i've got the big you got the big piece
of chicken right in the middle
so i know don't forget about me big
white chicken right in the middle i'm
right here okay but i will say this
i mean you make good points there's no
doubt they can't hire that coach
or be enemy until they got an answer
from a desean watson i think that is
something like you're bringing up the
right point they gotta they gotta talk
to him and be like
hey listen if we hire eric b enemy
you're good
you're going to be all in with the
organization things like that and then
they'll have to have eric bienami call
him off of that and be like hey
you're good me and you are going to do
special things right let's see what we
can do here
and then they go forward with it because
i mean
eric the enemy he's probably saying the
same thing as you too he might be going
i don't really want the job unless i
know deshawn watson is going to be there
you know this place looks a little crazy
too unless i know he's going to be there
so i think there's got to be a lot of
conversations that go on before some of
these decisions may
are made chris simms i'm wondering you
know you can be honest with us i'm
wondering when you do some of your fine
media work whether it's the chris
sims unbuttoned podcast or you're on
football night in america i wonder if
you make a point
you say oh that's a little that's a
little provocative but i already said it
and the red lights on so
you add more to it and then now you get
lost
i think i did that i think i did that
about five minutes ago ten minutes ago
where i said chris help me out i said
the buffalo bills are the best team in
football right now and i picked him
to beat the chiefs help me out is that
crazy or do i have a shot
no no it's not crazy not at all it's
it's
i think they're right there in the
running for the best team in football
i'm not going to pick them to win
i'm not going to pick anybody to beat
the chiefs in one of these games until i
see them beat the chiefs in one of these
games they're just one of those teams
that seem to rise to the challenge the
only time they didn't rise to the
challenge
they really rose to the challenge and
some guy lined up offsides on a fourth
down
i mean they had brady in new england on
the ropes so they're unbelievable that
way i'm gonna go with the chiefs in a
close
high scoring shootout i think the game
will be totally different than the first
time around i think both of these teams
will go wait
first time around we tried to be
balanced and run the ball and do those
things
they're not going to take that chance on
afc championship sunday
they're going to put the ball in mahm's
hands they're going to put the ball in
josh allen's hands
and say wait this is who got us here
we're going to go down
throwing our best punches with our best
guys here but
you know it's both mocha both match ups
or coin toss match-ups
i think where i favor the chiefs michael
holly
is i still worry about
the buffalo bills defense you know the
buffaloes really
good when they can play a ravens team
and go
wait they we can put all our eggs in to
stop the run
and oh it's the patriots okay we can put
all our eggs in to stop the run
oh it's the cardinals we can put all our
eggs into let's just stop the pass we
don't have to worry about the run
you saw them struggle against balance
type teams as far as the indianapolis
colts are concerned
and not that i expect the chiefs to be
balanced but like we saw last week they
can run it good enough to where you
can't just go
we don't have to worry about it i think
it's going to be a very close game but
ultimately i just think the chiefs have
a few more studs on defense that'll make
a play
to win them the game or get a stop and
some some type of close game fashion
whatever i'm mumbling
all right you guys you got chiefs and
now
you go we know who you got you wrote it
you you got a green bay in there
you ain't even got to explain it that
some was understood
need not be spoken we already know i'm
going with the tampa bay buccaneers
michael smith
oh oh going back i know
this is it wait this is my tom brady
look
really well listen i mean you know of my
thoughts on aaron rodgers that's the
greatest quarterback i've ever seen
you know but it's still a team sport and
it's a match-up sport too and i think
this is a tough matchup for the green
bay packers michael smith for me
it's gonna have to be rogers being
amazing for them to win the game
they're not gonna run the ball in the
tampa bay buccaneers nobody has all year
long
other than the minnesota vikings you
know and it's gonna have to be rogers
getting the ball out of his hands
quickly with the short passing game so
that pass rush can't get there
if they want to win the game i think
that's the way it's going to have to be
first time around they tried to call
aggressive downfield passes and things
like that and
he was under pressure constantly you
really look at this
the the the buccaneers five losses this
year
one of them was to the chiefs the other
four reverse
teams who drew brees get the ball out of
your hands quick uh
jared goff get the ball out of your
hands quick and i'm
oh and nick foles and the bears at that
time it was short passes get the ball
hand
out of your hands quick that to me is
the way to beat the buccaneers
but i just think the buccaneers on
offense they're overpowering offensive
line of course brady and the weapons
the defensive line in front seven i give
them the advantage there
so yes i'm going with team by two points
26 24 bucks over the packers
but i think it's going to have to be
rogers being special if if they want to
win
and and he might be able to do that of
course we know that
guys like you know it's cool no it's
good it hurts me
it really hurts me i'm not a person i
got hurt i'm just i'm just embarrassed
because i just thought i just knew you
it's not it's not about that i'm hurt
it's that i just thought that we were
here
you know what i mean it's just that's
just that part i'm like wow
i try to pick with my brain and not my
heart like and that's what's annoying
about me
too you know i picked the ravens to beat
the bills last week
but it's annoying because as soon as the
game turned on i'm going man come on
josh allen let's go
i was rooting for the bills i i i like
them
uh i have a feeling that could happen me
with the bucks now i did play for the
bucks and they do have a special place
in my heart too
uh i said earlier chris i'm taking i'm
picking the packers i'm picking the
packers but there is a large part of me
i'm conflicted about both these games
i'm picking the packers but there's a
large part of me that would love to see
brady get back
uh who roots for tom brady right but i
would actually like to see him be the
first quarterback to host the super bowl
and on the flip side i'm picking the
chiefs but i'm definitely pulling for
buffalo
i'm definitely a buffalo to win again
yeah
i hear you and the brady thing is
amazing i mean two teams
another super bowl appearance first team
ever to be at home hosting the super
bowl
that'll be amazing and i heard you guys
talk about it a little before too
listen you talk about the four
quarterbacks this weekend
you know the i think there's more
pressure on mahomes because he's the
king of the hill right now and it's josh
allen coming into town trying to take
him off that hill
but nobody has more pressure on them
this weekend than aaron rodgers you know
i love him to death i think he is the
man he is almost godly to me
but tom brady's already won
this year i mean if he lost somebody
mattered
see see i was about to say goodbye but
then you had to go say that so
sorry michael hold on because when
you're no hey no look man we get to keep
chris sims more i'm good but when you
say
pressure to me
that implies or again maybe i'm
inferring
that if he loses or if his team
loses that it's somehow going to be a
knock against
aaron rodgers maybe he thinks yeah maybe
maybe that's what he's thinking who
chris that's
we'll no roger maybe rogers
i that's what that's what i think i
think rogers is way too
smart self-aware understands
you know legacy everything like that
to where i think he realizes like oh
brady goes on another team and still
beats rogers or you know goes and wins
another super bowl
not that people like us will necessarily
think that way yeah we follow the sport
we're in the weeds we know
all this stuff but i think the common
casual fan
that's the person who's going to be
swayed by this matchup and then he'll
have to hear that type of crap when
yes i'm not michael smith i don't think
he thinks i if anything he's thinking
i'm 37 like not that he's got you know
but
you can't you notice chris you cannot
take these opportunities for granted
nothing's guaranteed like as much as i
like to say buffalo's gonna be here
because josh allen doesn't mean that
he'll always they got a pass to the
super bowl
a path to the super bowl so so likewise
how many more nfc championship games can
aaron rodgers afford
to not want the pressure
see aaron rodgers can't win the big one
i mean well
and me and you will be there to go you
know that's a bull crap statement and
that's what
okay cool because i i i
all these nfc championship games he's
been in there's only been one of them
where he's on the better team
and that was the one he won and all the
other ones
he was the lesser team in the matchup
and he can't play defense against beast
mode
and catch the onside kick against the
seahawks they should have gone in the
super bowl
he did everything right to beat the
league in one year
would you even if 50 15 in one year they
fell asleep at the wheel in the
divisional round against the giants who
came up there and beat them right
remember yeah you lied through a hail
mary at the end of the day no would you
say
a better team yeah i wouldn't say i
would say they would have better they
weren't the better team at 50 but they
didn't get to the nfc championship that
year that would be their fifth oh you
mean that's the championship
championship yeah i got you
the best one of the best playoff runs
i've ever seen
was aaron rodgers that year they won a
championship
and i think they went to atlanta that
year
it was incredible what aaron rodgers
that's i think it's one of the best
playoff games i've ever seen
in person in my life so he's capable
yeah when he turns it on
it's special but i don't think he's
going to turn it on on sunday
it like you heard me say
i think the bucks are the better team
but trust me when i had to come out and
write it and say it and do all those
things i kept going
man am i really going to pick against
aaron rodgers at home and lambeau field
and this type of football game i i i
can't believe i'm doing it either but
when i got
done in week six and i looked back at my
notes because i got these notes where
this is all i do is match up football
and i write all ooh i love it
so right writing yeah i do i'm a lefty
perfect script but email me someone else
um one of the things i wrote at the
bottom after that week six matchup i
went
buccaneers win this matchup nine out of
ten times this
ain't a good matchup for the green bay
packers and i'm just gonna try to stay
true to my studies
and that way that's that's really what
it came down to hey listen your logic is
undeniable brother
hey man enjoy your weekend for the
second straight week this is our friday
too
so appreciate you following me hey i'll
tell you what you're controlling
yourself
if i was still writing the column mike
smith i'd write a column than that
on the notes the no the study of
christians that's a good column
thanks man i can right there right now
i'll see you be good
brother hey thanks for watching brother
from another on youtube make sure you
hit subscribe before you leave and be
sure to watch
us 3 to 5 p.m eastern time
on peacock appreciate you